chef championne vending comme de nuit
julien dollars 25 dans votre machine et
j'aurais dû avoir des ménages
malheureusement je n'en ai pas eu j'ai
trouvé ça compte en riant parce que je
vais très fin et puis ma femme venait
mourir dix minutes plus tôt bras je ne
dis pas que c'est votre faute je veux
juste être précis julie a été quelqu'un
de bien elle était éducatrice
spécialisée elle grogner quand elle rien
maintenant qu'elle est morte je ne
ressemble ni tristesse et douleur
réparer le coeur humain c'est comme
réparer l'automobile il faut démonter
chaque pièce et toutes examinées et
après tu perds ton manque hélas je me
suis demandé et si ce n'est pas possible
c'est carette moreno de chez john john
wensink compagnie j'appelle au sujet de
vos lettres de réclamation c'était
quelqu'un qui parle et vous appelez
souvent vos clients à 2 heures du matin
j'aimerais bien ça bienvenue
et un peu de compassion on fait quoi
d'ailleurs ont démarré mon engagement
tu crois que c'est
pour recoller les morceaux